hello and welcome to big Fink live
I'm Jason gots and I'm here with Carter
Phipps
he's the executive editor of enlightened
next magazine and the author of the
forthcoming book evolutionary's
unlocking the spiritual and cultural
potential of Sciences greatest idea
Carter welcome to the program thank you
Jason
so central to your book is is the
concept of a type of person called an
evolutionary or that you're calling an
evolutionary could you help us to
understand what what that means what is
an evolutionary well an evolutionary my
favorite definition perhaps not the
simplest but my favorite is that an
evolutionary is a deep time Explorer of
a universe of infinite becoming now prep
the simpler definition would be it's a
new type of person a new type of thinker
a new type of intellectual a new type of
visionary who is beginning to connect
not just biological evolution in the
last you know three billion years of the
development of human life but also
cosmological evolution and beginning to
think about the human life and our human
culture in light of that whole history
that 13.7 you know billion years of
cosmological development biological
development and also cultural
development who's also beginning to
contextualize in a human life in the
last 10,000 years last forty thousand
years of the development of human
culture and beginning to connect those
you know kind of three periods of
evolutionary history together
to begin and to begin to think about
this kind of coherent story of what it
means to be human in that context you
know honoree Burke's and the great
philosopher of the early 20th century
late 19th century said you know our
intellects are not made to think
evolution think evolution mean we don't
think with a net that frame what I just
described around our cognition we don't
think about our lives in the context of
at historical context that developmental
context if you will if you will and
evolutionary's are people who are
beginning to do that the beginning the
place are the self and society in that
context and of course that also changes
the way you think about the past but it
begins to change the way you think about
the future as well
so if if I'm able to you know hold in my
mind the whole scope of human evolution
and allow that to kind of inform my
worldview like what are some of the ways
I mean I know it's it's a pretty vast
concept but I what are some of the ways
in which that might change the way I go
about living my everyday life like in in
the world well there's there's MIT can
have you know multiple effects on how we
see all kinds of things how we see you
know the institutions of human culture
at all levels political economic social
structure social institutions it but you
know it begins to kind of place our own
you know we start to recognize ourselves
as this sort of advanced advancing edge
in some sense of this vast process of
becoming and that's quite a powerful
position and place to see human
consciousness and human culture in light
of that vast evolutionary process and I
think you you know it places a kind of a
tremendous you know cuz from the but
from the perspective of time you know
that whole trajectory where as far as we
as far as we know where the evolutionary
will right at the edge we're right the
evolutionary edge from the perspective
of time and so when you start to see
yourself you know at the edge of this
kind of creative process that's giving
birth to to so much in the lat and all
you know that period whether whether we
track at the last 10,000 years the last
three billion years of the last 13.7
billion years it's given birth to so
much in terms of the creativity of this
whole process then when you start to
think about our life like that starts to
you start to you start
change the way you relate to your sense
of what's you know of what human life is
and the meaning in human life and then
when we start to think about culture in
the last hundreds of years the last
thousands of years and we see the way in
which we've developed as a species and
the progress we've made and the
challenges we faced and the difficulties
we've had we see it in light of this
prog project of human development and
the betterment of the human condition
over time you know we start to have a
deeper faith in the potential of the
future and a deeper sense of optimism
about what's possible for the future not
like a naive Optus optimism not like we
know things are gonna be better than the
past but the sense of while we see this
developmental process we've been on as
human beings and and it's creating art
this society and we see that the
struggles and this trajectory but we see
the way we've kind of built up from you
know this hunter-gatherers with all the
problems we have and all the
difficulties of our civilization we also
see these incredible the incredible
breakthroughs in progress we made and we
start to see things in light of that
context it gives us this the sense of
potential and meaning and faith and and
and also it kind of empowers that sense
of responsibility for taking the next
step and for being responsible for that
next step so help me understand this so
like you know for me I feel that we've
as a species we've made progress in many
many ways in other ways we you know seem
to languish and some of the old ancient
you know difficulties of our species sir
you know and and and of course like if
we were ever to arrive at the point when
which you know thankfully didn't happen
during the Cold War where we blew
ourselves up with some technology that
wasn't available when we were cavemen
then would say well what really happened
overall you know do you see the whole
thing as progressing in a positive sense
or do you simply see it as like okay
evolution shows us that it's possible to
make progress in in certain significant
dimensions
that teaches us that therefore we can
move forward not that like there's a
that there's a grand design that we are
moving forward I don't believe in grand
designs you know I don't believe I
believe in this trajectory of
development that we've been on and the
potential of that trajectory to continue
and I believe in this you know this
sense of that as you said the sense of
potential progress but I don't believe
anything's inevitable and I don't
believe there's any definite map that
exists ahead of us
I I think progress is a delicate word
obviously and there's been a lot of
people have rejected the whole notion of
progress completely a lot of
evolutionary thinkers where I have it
rejected you know evolutionary
scientists have rejected the whole
notion of progress but I think we're
starting to see it and much of that had
to do with the nature of the 20th
century in the two world wars and that
sense that that evolutionary ideas can
be dangerous if they're not if we don't
have a very rich understanding of
evolution evolutionary ideas can be
dangerous and sometimes very naive and
very you know all kinds of mischief was
created by very backward what we call
timoni called great limited very narrow
ideas about what constitutes evolution
and culture you know in some of you know
some of a lot of the problems in 20th
century were created by that so there's
kind of this hesitation to begin to
speak about these ideas so we can add
that as context to how we think about it
but nevertheless I think if you you know
I do think you can track this
progression of human history in all
kinds of ways in my book I go through
different thinkers who track it in
different ways you can look at the
evolution of of you know culture the
evolution of economic institutions the
evolution of you know worldviews the
evolution of Technology the evolution of
politics the evolution of you know
deeper issues like the evolution of
consciousness at some level the
evolution of perspectives the evolution
you can you can track evolution along
different different trajectories but I
think they all point to this overall
development that is occurring now the
riki part of development is that there's
always this progress and pathology point
meaning that even as we make certain
progress we have we create new problems
with that progress so the Western
enlightenment and Industrial Revolution
was this tremendous progress in an
uplift of the human condition in so many
ways yet it created its own series of
pathologies it's a massive series of
pathologies which are incredibly
dangerous simply because it's like the
power of the progress itself makes the
power of the pathologies that much more
tricky and that much more and so then
the new way a new a new worldview sort
of arose to begin to address those
pathologies and so you see this this
dialect you know this dialectic
relationship in the development of
history so there's nothing guaranteed
and there's no and you know and each new
level creates its own issues and its own
difficulties and we have to take
responsibility for those and but we're
starting to think to recognize more how
that is happening the more we recognize
how that is happening the more we can
actually take responsibility for that
process because we've been we haven't
known where on this developmental
trajectory over the last 20 years we
haven't known this this is new
information in culture not just a
cosmological evolution or biological
evolution but cultural evolution and
some of this is he's just beginning to
work its way into into our thought and
so it's like it's like we're suddenly
waking up and so it's like you're in the
car and you're waking up and suddenly
it's like you're you're on the road
you're going somewhere and you have to
take control of the steering wheel in
some sense and of course if you're if
you're kind unconscious and you're kind
of wine you have a lot of wrecks you
know and you kind of steer as best you
can you just try to go for open space
yeah but but if you're if you start to
wake up then you start to see some of
the dynamics of evolution over the last
10,000 years and all the difficulties
but also the progress and the
development then you can start we can
start to take more you know on our
shoulders and see more what you know and
take it and that's what people mean when
they use the term conscious evolution
they mean consciously taking
responsibility for this process that's
no longer completely unconscious I'm can
reduce the pathology and increase the
progress you know so right right so I I
wonder also I mean the ideas in your
emerge out of you know conversations
you've been having things you've
observed as we've been the executive
editor of enlighten next magazine and
also out of the thinking in enlightened
next the organization yes and Andrew
Cohen who we've interviewed as well um
and I wonder what whether any kind of
dialogue positive negative both in
between you know what has been happening
between you guys with these ideas about
evolutionary enlightenment and evolution
as a kind of lens for viewing the world
and the you know quote-unquote harder
sciences of yeah evolutionary biology
and so on like have there been
conversations has there been pushed back
what what's what what's happening there
well yes and no yes in the sense that we
we love to interview scientists in the
magazine and we did you know a great we
often did and we have some great
dialogues with scientists who were
exploring some of the edges of their own
field and some of the implications of
their own fields in different ways
including evolutionary scientists so
there's certainly a dialogue there and
there's certainly interest there I still
think that mainstream when you talk
about you know we were in in light next
magazine we were coming at this from a
more spirit from spiritually oriented
perspective and if you're talking about
mainstream evolutionary ideas
evolutionary biology daily ontology you
know there's that's just that they they
don't really see that it's the four that
doesn't really use the spiritual side of
things doesn't really exist you know
it's like it's just kind of noise in the
background of the knowledge experiment
you know so I think that's I mean that's
probably an exaggeration but for the
most part you know it's going to take
more and look and understandably look
there's been a lot of of theological and
spiritual ideas that were you know just
not really not really worthy of a deep
rational inquiry they weren't they just
weren't on the same playing field but to
me there's nothing about spirituality or
even theology that has to be dogmatic
there has to be supernatural and then
with it you know a spiritual inquiry
into reality can be rational it can be
it can be it can be important it can be
a profound inquiry into what knowledge
is and it may not be explicitly
scientific it may be you know if there's
like a range as a scientific there's the
philosophical there's the spiritual and
they all can to me they all can explore
knowledge they all can explore the
knowledge of this of this universe you
know perhaps in different ways with
different tools but but they don't have
to be inherently at odds anyway that's
that's the next book by the way yeah I
mean I I think this is my last question
which is you know I've been thinking
about and will be writing an article
soon about the about consciousness and
the study of consciousness in
neuroscience you know and there are
these areas in science which are sort of
considered fringed by the mainstream
they have difficulty getting funding or
whatever because of the unknowns are so
many of the variables are so many and
it's much easier to get funding for sort
of incremental studies of cyanobacteria
or whatever right right and you you
recently wrote an article about sort of
the need for generalists and the sort of
tendency to hyper specialization right
so I wonder you know whether you have
any thoughts about how how this kind of
generalist thinking you know can can
actually push forward you know some of
our are harder Sciences some of our you
know the growth of our technology and
all of these other things in ways that
wouldn't happen if we're stuck in these
kind of angry antal you know wasn't
thinking I think it's a real issue this
kind of siloed thinking and you know and
of course specialization and and looking
at you know narrow or narrower fields
and areas of knowledge and science can
be quite powerful you know you know they
like to say about what about the
specialists you you know you know more
and more about less and less until
eventually you know
you know more and more about less and
less until you eventually you know
everything about nothing you know in the
generalist
I guess the danger is on the other hand
you know less and less about more and
more and so eventually you know nothing
about everything but but there's a
there's a power in specialization and
the way science has produced that and
you can say over the last I do think of
the last several hundred years we've
been in this process of more and more
specialization as we kind of branched
out to this incredible diversity the way
we explore the natural world and the
world itself and all its tiny
manifestations so there's nothing
inherently wrong with that that's been
this incredible explosion of data and
knowledge but now you feel we lack we
lack ways to integrate all that we lack
meaning to kind of put around that we
lack frames to put around all this these
pictures you know as I say in that blog
were we're data rich and you know
context poor and and in order to really
to understand things more deeply
sometimes you have to use knowledge from
this area in this area in this area you
have to begin to put those together a
new integrative theories that include
more than just one siloed area of
knowledge I think it's good that's
critical for for moving understanding
forward in various ways not for
everything but for some things it's
absolutely critical and one of the
things I'd be getting we noticed as we
begin to interview more of these
evolutionary thinkers is that they were
you know where they came from spiritual
with a spiritual side of things where
they came from scientific side of things
where they were philosophers they were
incredibly well informed generalists and
they were taking they weren't afraid to
take knowledge from here and apply this
to that and the Vista human culture and
this from the sciences and this from
philosophy and this from you know some
thinker here and you know there and they
were bringing it all together and these
kind of more integrated forms and I
think the power of evolution in some
sense is it's an integrative force even
in biology this was Theodore Tibbs on
skis great insight you know he said
nothing in biology makes sense except in
light of evolution because evolution was
this you know integrative function it
provided there before evolution you know
biology was all these kind of disparate
ideas and theories and classifications
and when evolution came along it's sort
of integrated at all and you begin to
understand it in light of that one
picture but I think evolution it has
that POW it has that potential
relationship to other areas of knowledge
as well even the way we understand
culture so I think nothing in human
culture
you could argue makes sense except in
light of this evolutionary understanding
because it puts this big frame around
things it begin you can start to
integrate in various ways and and and
knowledge starts to relate to this this
overall trajectory of this evolutionary
unfolding and you note a hard dish are
Dan the Jesuit priest and paleontologist
he said it beautifully he said you know
evolution is a light that illumines all
facts a curve that all lines must follow
and it speaks to this integrative
function of evolutionary ideas Carter
Phipps thank you so much for being with
us today thank you very much and we
invite our big think audience to visit
Carter Phipps that's pH I double P s
comm to learn more about his new book
evolutionary's and please check back to
Big Think calm to watch additional video
clips from our conversation with Carter
and to find out about future live
interviews with our experts thank you
for watching and Carter thanks again for
being with us thank you very much
you